[Musique]
euh bonjour merci de votre fidélité je
voulais vous signaler cette phrase de
rayond Chandler puisque nous allons
parler de Pol de polar inventé de Pol
réel vous savez crémon Chand c'est
l'auteur américain du Grand Sommeil l'un
des plus grands auteurs de polarard du
20e siècle les cadavres sont plus lourds
que les cœurs brisés écrit-il justement
dans le grand sommeil nous allons tout à
l'heure parler dans la troème partie
justement de l'importance du polarard
dans la littérature et de l'importance
du réel aussi dans la littérature nous
sommes avec deux patrons rédaction
Jacques expert qui a dirigé à peu près
toutes les entreprises que Herby gatgo
n'a pas dirigé et l'inverse puisqu'il
s'agit de M6 de RTL de Paris Match du
Journal du Dimanche maintenant de Radio
Classique pour
et et Jacques Jean passe puisque vous
avez été aussi enquêteur grand reporter
à France Inter et vous étiez spécialiste
desffit d'hiver Jacques publie le grand
test c'est un polar qui est publié chez
Kalman Levy c'est loin d'être son
premier livre il a été édité par sonatin
le grand éditeur de polarard pendant
très très longtemps et nous allons
parler donc de cette affaire qui se
passe dans un petit village ou plutôt
une petite commune de Sologne qui
s'appelle saven et qui m au prix
justement un trio qui est impliqué
dans un crime on sait depuis le début
c'est là la force d'exert mais qui
attend le verdict de la gendarmerie et
ce verdict va passer par un grand test
avec HERV gatgot Hervé c'est un cadavre
sur la route de l'Élysée les derniers
secrets de l'affaire Markovic c'est une
enquête qui est publiée aux éditions
flamarion mais c'est d'une certaine
manière comment peut-on dire le
déboussoillage de tout ce qui reste de
l'enquête policière des dossiers
notamment de ceux qu'avit randumain que
vous avez rencontré puisquil représenta
les partis civiles et qui représentait
donc Markovic qui a été assassiné en 68
on va y venir dans un instant ça nous
permettra de parler de l'ensemble des
affaires qui ont secoué la 5e République
dans la 3e partie de l'émission je
commence donc avec le camarade expert je
le disais Jacques vous n'en êtes pas à
votre premier livre euh celui-là se
passe donc dans une petite commune qui
s'appelle saven n on est en Sologne il y
a 2000 habitants et voici que disparaît
un peu le le le personnage le potenta
local qui est l'adjoint au maire et qui
a une grande entreprise qui consiste à
découper les volailles et un beau jour
on le retrouve mort grillé dans une
grange qui est attenante à sa maison
c'est un personnage qui est à la fois
aimé et détesté par la communauté de ce
village qui a un fils Germain qui fait
donc plus ou moins du trafic de drogue
et donc puisqu'on ne trouve pas le
coupable de de cette affaire le gendarme
qui va diriger l'enquête décide de faire
un grand test qui d'ailleurs a lieu dans
dans les affaires classiques qu'on a
connu ces derniers temps et que vous
connaissez CIT l'affaire Estel Mousin et
cetera et cetera c'est même dans
l'affaire vilemain que j'ai suivi ils
ont pass ils ont fait un grand test de
sur l'écriture là c'est un grand test
sur une empreunte digitale qu'on a
trouvé sur ce qu'on considère être
l'arme du crime celle qui a qui celle
qui a servi à assommer le le notable
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure donc il
a une don vous parlez c'est plutôt votre
votre héros négatif mais en tout cas
c'est ce personnage que vous avez
inventé vous avez un goût justement pour
cette France qui est un peu la France
des gilets jaunes et pour les
personnalité c'est ce sont des petits
lieux on sent qu'il y a chez vous ce
goût un peu à la à la simnon d'aller
fouiller des personnalité dans des
endroits qui sont des endroits
classiques de la France classique alors
vous citez Simenon qui est mon auteur de
polar favori c'est le meilleur
compliment le meilleur parallèle qu'on
puisse me faire alors si vous voulez-
moi ce qui ce qui m'intéresse au-delà du
fait divhivers c'est les individus dans
leur complexité et là un trio et c'est
ça qui m'intéresse c'est-à-dire vous
savez vous moi Hervé on n'est pas on
n'est pas un espèce de on n pas
monolithique on a des des failles des
cassures et cetera et moi c'est c'est ça
qui m'intéresse d'ailleurs quand j'étais
journaliste c'est toujours ce qui m'a
intéressé quand je suivis les affaires
des affaires des faits divers quand j'ai
suivi même des événements internationaux
j'ai
toujours raconté ces événements à
travers ce qu'il y avait dans la tête
des gens ce qu'il y a dans la tête dans
votre tête je suis désolé ça m'intéresse
voici la phrase clé de cette affaire
tant que leur trio faisait corps il
tenaient maintenant Alexandre est
cuisiné par les flics Alexandre est un
type extrêmement brillant sont un trio
de jeunes il y a
Virginia donc il y en a un troisè qui
s'appelle Maxence et ils ont un 4è
personnage qui s'appelle Anatole qui est
un peu disons celui qu'on pourrait
qualifier si on était romantique de
désaccé de la bande mais ces trois là et
c'est comme ça que vous avez construit
le livre ils savent depuis le début qu's
sont impliqués dans cette affaire et ils
voient la mécanique de la gendarmerie
procédé par l'enquête et ils veulent
savoir et c'est toute la tension il
construit livre s'ils vont
échapper à la gendarmerie incarné par du
Ken et incarné par le juge dial ou s ils
vont au contraire plonger dans toute
l'affaire voilà alors ce ce livre que
vous disez s'appelle le grand test c'est
un grand test donc à l'échelle de
village pour savoir qui a déposé son
emprunte digitale c'est un grand test
sur cette amitié solide qui date de 20
ans depuis l'enfance des TR des trois et
c'est aussi un un test entre une amitié
entre le entre un juge et le gendarme
qui dirige l'enquête donc c'est si vous
voulez c'est il y a trois tiroirs une
enquête trois amis parce que le juge
peut à tout moment le dessaisir si le
grand test nabouti à rien du tout et
c'est là où justement le livre est malin
et plein de retournements c'est à
l'évidence au départ on a l'impression
que Jacques vous donne la solution
puisque'un personnage est arrêté puis il
est relâché puis après c'est Alexandre
qui est extraordinairement suspecté et
lui-même sait qu'il est plus ou moins
coupable mais entre plus et moins il y a
une énorme différence il y a une
histoire d'amour entre Virginien et
Maxence et puis il y a tout un village
il y a un café de la mairie il y a un
maire il y a le père de Virginia il y a
un journaliste qui est pas très bon pour
notre profession qui est vraiment un
ringard total et qui avale absolument
tout ce qu'on veut lui faire raconter on
sent le vécu chez vous
Jacques j'ai d'ailleurs été interrogé
cette semaine par le correspondant local
parce que j'y vais samedi dans un
village du coin et le correspondant qui
n'est pas celui du du du livre m'a
interrogé cette semaine il m'a dit
j'espère que je ressemble pas à celui
qui est dans le roman alors comment vous
avez eu l'idée parce que vous avez
publié une quinzaine de livres comment
vous avez eu l'idée justement de mettre
en avant comme mécanique cette histoire
du grand en fait on a un village il y a
le grand test qui arrive et forcément
tout le village se demande qui a déposé
les empreintes en sachant que évidemment
dans la mécanique perverse de ce garçon
qui s'appelle expert ne croyez pas que
ce qui apparaît comme l'évidence et la
réalité qui va vous décrire
ouais chaque chacun de mes livres un
point de départ qui qui fait germer une
idée dans dans ma tête là je j'ai dû le
dire dans un journal qui avait un grand
test dans un dans une ville autour de
l'ADN on faisait tout passer tout le
monde à à l'ADN parce qu'on a trouvé
l'ADN sur une arme de crime là pourquoi
j'ai pris l'empo digital c'est que comme
il y a deux garçons et une fille il
fallait que ce soit parce que l'ADN
féminin est différent de de l'ADN
masculin donc ça aurait immédiatement
écarté la la jeune fille des des
criminels potentiels donc j'ai choisi
l'empoint digital et c'est et c'est vrai
que tout le l'un des suspens du livre
c'est se demander lequel des trois
à à assainer le coup mortel sur ce sur
ce notable et et et je dirais aussi le
suspense c'est est-ce que leur amitié
solide profonde qui a 20 ans plus de 20
ans d'âge est-ce qu'elle va résister à
ça elle ne résiste pas à ça non parce
que vous savez je je me suis on dit
souvent que l'amitié est plus forte que
l'amour qu'elle résiste à tout ça j'y
crois pas je crois que quand on est
confronté à une
situation dramatique où on risque de
soi-même sa sa vie peut-être que
l'amitié explose à ce moment-là et
malgré les promesses qu'on peut se faire
euh ce qui est intéressant comme autre
aspect du suspense je disais tout à
l'heure c'est que Hervé connaît ça aussi
dans les rapports qui des enquêtes
puisqu'il s'agit d'une enquête et c'est
pareil d'ailleurs dans le livre sur
Markovic il y a toujours la personnalité
du juge et des enquêteurs et le juge est
toujours si l'enquête n'avance pas dans
le choix possible de transférer de la
gendarmerie ou SRPJ et il y a évidemment
sur duken cette pression totale que même
s'il arrive presque presque à la
solution il n'a pas la solution et la
hiérarchie judiciaire va dire bon
maintenant c'est terminé tu es d saaisi
c'est exactement ce qui se passe dans
cette affaire là où expert je vous le
disais tout à l'heure est évidemment un
grand pervers mais un pervers
extrêmement fréquentable c'est que vous
n'avez la solution que au chapitre
98 donc vous êtes tenu pendant 97
chapitres par un suspense qui est
formidablement réussi vous avez écrit je
disais euh beaucoup de livres tout à
l'heure on évoquait Jacques des
personnalités on va voir grâce à nos
amis réalisateurs quelques citations de
gens qui ont un rapport justement avec
l'univers du polar comme Paul her ou
Agatha Christie vous disiez tout à
l'heure votre grand goût de de simnon
mais ce n'est pas le seul j'aimerais
bien qu'on nous les montre justement ces
citations de pauloster et d'Agata
Christie alors par exemple pauloster
grand auteur américain qui n'est pas un
grand spécialiste du polar dans un bon
roman policier rien n'est perdu il n'y a
pas de phrase ni de beau qui ne soit pas
significatif et là nous sommes dans le
cadre de la littérature justement
comment ça s'écrit un bon polar
euh je me demande j'ai pas vraiment la
réponse moi j'ai une façon très
personnelle d'écrire c'estàd par exemple
sur le grand test je suis parti d'un
pitch très simple trois amis confronté à
cette à cette épreuve et à partir de là
je pars l'aventure je fais pas de plan
pas la fin c'est la fin que vous dont
vous parlez qui arrive au chapitre
98 c'est pas au chapitre 98 qu'on la
trouve elle s'impose petit à petit mais
je ne l'avais pas au départ du livre
c'est comme ça et dans tous mes romans
j'enis fait j'ai fait 14 polars le 14e
celui-là dans tous j'étais je suis
incapable d'écrire en plan et dans aucun
je connais la fin nous passons à Hervé
nous allons continuer notre conversation
avec Jacques alors là on est dans un
parce que la mort est un roman mais là
il s'agit d'une mort réelle il s'agit
pas simplement d'un potentat local dans
un petit village il s'agit de Stéphane
Markovic qui est un youoslave playboy
donc qui est l'homme à tout faire
d'Alain Delon dans l'histoire de
Markovic je reprends mes notes parce que
c'est important il faut le savoir donc
il disparaît le 22 septembre
68 et
donc on découvre son cadavre le 1er
octobre
68 dans une espèce de couverture euh et
le tout dans une décharge qui est du
côté d'élancour donc tout le monde le
sait cette affaire c'est une enquête
criminelle une affaire politique car
elle va toucher georgees Pompidou mais
commençons par cette enquête criminelle
qui est un vrai semblable puisqu'elle va
durer tenez-vous bien de 68 à
76 comment ça se fait que ça a duré si
longtemps alors en réalité la procédure
a duré de 68 à 76 parce que oui c'est
très long à l'échelle de de du travail
ordinaire de la justice dans les
affaires criminell malheureusement en
France c'est finalement assez proche de
la moyenne mais surtout dans cette
affaire ce qui est fascinant c'est que
de 68 à fin 69 il y a un travail
policier judiciaire intense tout est
fait pour essayer de trouver la solution
après l'élection de Georges Pompidou à
la présidence de la République bah
finalement cette affaire elle passe en
quelque sorte en dessous de la pile il
va même y avoir des pressions je le
raconte dans mon livre pour que la
justice n'aboutisse pas au résultat et
puis finalement l'affaire va dormir
prendre la poussière pendant des années
et 76 c'est vraiment l'aboutissement
procédural c'est-àd la dernière décision
de la Cour de cassation qui finalement
acte le fiasco judiciaire puisque
personne n'a été condamné pour le
meurtre de Stéphane Markovic alors Marc
Anthony donc est entre guillemets
peut-être au conditionnel l'homme qui a
procédé ou fait procéder à l'exécution
donc de de Markovic on pense que
peut-être Alain Delon est à l'origine de
cette volonté de disparition mais tout
ça n'est absolument pas prouvé même
quand quand vous avez déclassifié tous
les dossiers tout lu il faut savoir que
de long à 33 ans quand il est interrogé
pour la première fois par la police et
c'est là où le personnage est inoui
d'une certaine manière c'est qu'à la
fois vous le suspectez mais vous lui
rendez hommage c'est l'homme qui a quand
même déjà tourné à 33 ans plein soleil
le guépard le samouraï Roco et ses
frères enfin c'est la superstar du
cinéma européen avec plusieurs séjours
donc en Californie et quand il était
interrogé en plein tournage de la
piscine il est de marbre c'est le
samouraï il a été interrogé 15 fois par
la police et à aucun moment il a donné
pratiquement pas le sentiment de de
craquer oui il est indéchiffrable en
fait on ne sait pas probablement parce
que c'est un immense acteur on ne sait
pas quand c'est Alain Delon personnage
de fiction ou quand c'est Alain Delon
personnage réel qui s'exprime et les
policiers sont totalement désarçonnés
face à lui il est vrai que il est donc
interrogé pour la première fois pendant
le tournage de la piscine quelques jours
jours après la découverte du corps de
Markovic parce que Markovic donc il faut
je le répète pour qu'on soit concret
pour ceux qui ont oublié cette histoire
de la fin des années 60 qui est devenu
un scandale politique Markovic c'est son
homme à tout faire il dans VO son ami il
habite chez lui à venu de Messine dans
un hôtel particulier il est au passage
aussi l'AND de sa femme Nathalie Delon
parce que leur couple badlelle
d'ailleurs d'on le reconnaît elle le
reconnaît
aussi donc de ce point de vue là tout
est disons je dis pas normal mais en
tout cas tout est assumé pendant la
procédure et assumé et même assumé et
même banalisé par euh par Delon et au
fond euh ce qu'on voit bien dans les
dans les auditions euh d'Alain Delon par
la police et par la justice c'est que au
fond il il il reste entièrement
impassible quoi qu'on lui oppose quelle
que soit la question qu'on lui pose il
reste impassible il met tout à à
distance euh j'jouait que euh quand il
est interrogé pendant le tournage de la
piscine il vient 3 jours auparavant
avant de tourner la scène dans le film
la piscine dans laquelle il est
interrogé lui-même par un inspecteur de
police qui a l'air dès le début de
comprendre que c'est lui le coupable et
donc il y a un petit jeu du chat et de
la souris pour ceux qui ont vu le film
dans la réalité ça ressemble énormément
à ça alors sauf que la police n'a pas de
raison de le soupçonner d'emblé mais
d'emblé Deon installe une ambiance
particulière et et se et se montre au
fond en permanence inaccessible la
police n'arrive jamais à comprendre où
il va et pourquoi il dit ce qu'il dit
grande thèse d'Hervé il n'a jamais tout
dit concernant de longon après il faut
essayer de comprendre les raisons pour
lesquelles
évidemment ce cadavre alors vous allez
découvrir l'état du cadavre de Markovic
grâce à la phase qui va apparaître et à
la réalisation le crâne de l'inconnu a
été défoncé le cerveau réduit en bouilli
son visage porte des marque de coup et
des PL la mâchoire est à moitié arrachée
donc le tout dans dans dans une sorte de
de couverture les enquêteurs du SRPJ de
versaill vont mettre 2 ans pour
radiographer tous les gens qui ont
acheté le même sorte de tissu et il y
aura cinq personnes qui ne pourront pas
expliquer ou donner d'explications
valables pour les pour les flics c'est
Marc anony parmi les cinq d'où le fait
qu'il soit le suspect numéro 1 ça c'est
une enquête qui aurait intéressé Jacques
expert parce que c'est vraiment une une
enquête criminelle euh
formidable impressionnante Markovic il y
a plusieurs solutions est-ce qu'il est
mort parce qu'il faisait chanter de long
si est très possible parce que cette
situation vous la décrivez il est très
mal à l'aise dans cet hôtel particulier
il en a marre d'être la doublure il en a
marre de ne pas profit il devient il
devient jaloux de son de son ami de son
bienfaiteur et dans un processus
psychologique finalement assez classique
il se met à lui en vouloir et il devient
même vindicatif envers lui dans les
jours qui précèdent sa mort il raconte à
beaucoup de ses amis que il a
l'intention de s'en prendre à de long
soit soit de le voler soit de le faire
enlever soit de le compromettre par le
chantage et en effet il envoie des
lettres à son frère en Yougoslavie pour
lui dire que s'il lui arrive malheur ce
qui montre qu'il a peur et il a raison
d'avoir peur s' lui arrive malheur il
faudra s'adresser à Marc Anthony
gangster amis d'Alain Delon et à Alain
Delon c'est la deuxème piste c'està-dire
est-ce que donc Marc Anthony aurait pu
donc faire disparaître Markovic parce
qu'il a lui aussi avec Markovic des
petits braquages du trafic alors Marc
Antony quel est son quel est son rôle
là-dedans en dehors du fait qu'il est
suspect numéro 1 ne serait-ce que parce
qu'il a une maison à une une trentaine
de minutes ou une trentaine de
kilomètres de la décharge d' lancours
alors Marc Anthony c'est un gangster
c'est une figure du milieu à l'époque
qui s'est toujours débrouillé pour
échapper aux choses les plus graves
qu'on lui reprochait il a eu des petites
condamnations mais donc la police le
considère comme un très grand personnage
du milieu et donc quand elle tombe sur
lui elle est au fond convaincu dès le
départ que il a quelque chose à voir
avec ce crime euh dans ce crime il est
évident que il y a la proximité entre
Marc Anthony et Delon qui joue Marc
Anthony peut être celui qui rend des
services à Delon euh il peut aussi être
celui qui protège Delon dans certaines
circonstances je raconte dans mon livre
que parfois Delon est menacé par le
milieu notamment pour les films qu'il
fait euh et puis il y a aussi un autre
ingrédient c'est que Marc Anthony a une
pro imité avec la politique Marc Anthony
c'est un homme qui est lié au réseau du
sac au réseau il a été dans la
Résistance voilà il a fait une petite
résistance mais il il est considéré
comme blessé de guerre il utilise
faussement la qualité de de de résistant
et de décorer ce ce qui va être
découvert par la justice pendant
l'enquête mais donc son réseau politique
est probablement important aussi et
georgees Pompidou lorsque la rumeur va
venir mettre en cause son couple dans
cette affaire Pompidou va assez vite
soupçonner que c'est une diversion et
qu'on essaie d'éloigner la police et la
justice de la vraie piste autrement dit
de la piste Marc anony sur la base de
mon enquête je crois que Pompidou
n'avait pas tort quand il faisait cette
confidence à Jacques fucard Le
l'éminence grise du général de Gaulle
alors ce qui est extraordinaire dans
cette enquête et on l'a un peu oublié et
onaborde la troisème partie que nous
allons
évidemment tenir avec à la fois Jacques
et avec Hervé c'est de l'Ance de ce
qu'on appelait d'une manière un peu
péjorative les Hugos dans la vie
mondaine et dans la vie des truants de
l'époque ils sont partout dans
l'entourage de Delon puis surtout
puisque c'est là que nous arrivons à la
politique vous avez connu cette période
Jacques en prison un dénommé arkof qui
fait exploser l'affaire dans l'autre
dimension que la dimension politique en
disant et en témoignant devant la police
et ça arrive évidemment à l'Élysée au
ministère de l'Intérieur en disant que
que Markovic se promenait dans les
parties fines du côté de Montfort laamis
avec un appareil et qu'il avait
évidemment photographié tout le monde
dont la femme d'un ancien ministre en
clair madame George Pompidou et c'est là
qu'évidemment le le l'enquête criminel
bascule totalement oui c'est là qu'on
passe du du du thriller policier au
thriller politique et au fond moi c'est
ce qui m'a toujours intéressé dans cette
affaire intuitivement j'étais convaincu
ayant lu toutes les biographies de
Georges Pompidou et tous les livres sur
cette
époque queil fallait rapprocher la
chronologie policière de la chronologie
politique et non pas les éloigner pour
comprendre l'affaire et donc
effectivement Pompidou fin 68 a été
limogé par De Gaulle à la suite des
événements de Mai 68 il attend un jour
de pouvoir lui succéder mais il se
demande quand la chose pourra se
produire et au fond il est à ce
moment-là fragile parce que il reste un
personnage très envié très jalousé qui a
beaucoup de rivaux qui se préparent eux
aussi pour la succession du général mais
il est faible parce qu'il est éloigné du
pouvoir il n'a plus tous les réseaux
vous vous souvenez de cette période
Jacques oui oui je me souviens de cette
période je me souviens surtout au-delà
du crime de Markovic de la de la façon
dont le président Pompidou a été sali
dans cette affaire c'est on le sent
d'ailleurs dans votre livre et et ce qui
m'a frappé ce que je savais pas c'était
la c'était que qu'il a pas été soutenu
par de Gaul de Gaul l'a quasiment ignoré
la même même retenu son son envie de le
défendre et c'estd le le le principal
principal collaborateur de De Gaulle on
est dans le weekend de la toussin de
Gaulle était à la Boisserie tricot donc
Bernard tri il récupère avec Marcelin et
Capitan qui sont des ennemis de Pompidou
toutes les informations il les porte à
de Gaulle et de Gaul considérant que la
famille Pompidou a des relations non pas
avec le showbiz mais avec les artistes
tout ça finalement ne serait pas
totalement étonnant et il laisse faire
ce qu'il n'aurait jamais dû laisser
faire au fond il n'aurait jamais dû
laisser faire mais je précise sur la
base de mon enquête que que ils ont
menti au général de Gaulle c'est-à-dire
que Bernard tricot et Capitan le garde
des saau ont noirci le tableau en
quelque sorte il présente à de Gaulle
une situation qui est déjà extrêmement
détériorée sur le plan judiciaire c'est
ils lui disent il y a un dossier qui est
ouvert c'est entre les mains de la
justice et il y a des éléments qui
compromettent Pompidou et là de Gaul a
la position qu'on lui connaît qu'il
avait déjà eu au moment de l'affaire Ben
Barca c'est il dit si la justice est
saisie il faut laisser travailler la
justice donc d'une certaine façon c'est
à son honneur mais Pompidou ne sait pas
que les principaux collaborateurs de de
Gaul lui ont menti et donc Pompidou va
nourrir une une immense rancœur envers
le général en disant mais donc le
général a cru que c'était possible et
c'est vrai qu'il l'a cru il l'a cru sur
la base de ces préjugés culturels dont
vous parliez Guillaume et qui sont vrais
mais il l'a cru aussi sur la base du
mensonge du garde des saut et du
secrétaire général de l'Élysée de
l'époque ce qui n'est pas rien
pardonnez-moi donc le grand test Jacques
expert les passions humaines les amitiés
la mécanique impitoyable de la
gendarmerie mais c'est une mécanique
vous le verrez je ne dis pas qu'elle va
dérailler parce que je ne vais pas dire
la fin du livre de Jacques mais il se
passe des choses qui sont évidemment
imprévues avec Hervé vous trouverez
cette affaire qui est la grande affaire
justement de la 5e République naissante
tous les détails sont là puisque c'est
la déclassification des dossiers qu'on
ne connaissait pas et notamment la
partie qui était couverte en tout cas
par Roland duas puisqu'il était donc
l'avocat de Markovic qu'il a eu la
gentillesse de vous donner donc la
possibilité d'y avoir accès lors d'un
dîner il avait 100 ans ce jour-là et
c'est grâce à à ce dîner où vous l'avez
convaincu alors que lorsque vous étiez
au monde vous l'avez bien balancé et
bien que vous avez pu écrire ce cadavre
sur la route de déliser donc les
derniers secrets de l'affaire Markovic
il y a tous les détails dans le livre
d'Hervé je vais vous proposer d'autres
livres ensemble alors un que vous
connaissez que j'ai choisi parce que
vous vous avez beaucoup travaillé pour
son latine pour une dizaine pour une
dizaine de romans c'est ho qui est un
anglais qui vient de publier Herta qui
est un des plus grands auteurs de polar
aujourd'hui et c'est vraiment le le
magicien de la mafia lui dans un autre
registre là c'est un choix que j'ai fait
vous conclurez tout à l'heure vous le
connaissez bien c'est un bon choix il a
fait des livres exceptionnels lequel est
le meilleur moi j'aime beaucoup les
apparences il y en a deux que j'aime
beaucoup c'est Vandetta qui est sont
second et les apparences qui je crois il
sont premier qui sont des livres qui qui
sont dans le panthéon de du Polard pour
moi voilà et en plus ce qui est étonnant
dans le cas de lor c'est que c'est via
son éditeur français qui est devenu un
auteur mondial grand auteur justement de
roman c'est l'espagnol Antonio MOS
Molina tu es pas dans l'escalier c'est
un chef-dœuvre absolu que nous vous
recommandons grâce à Fabrice Gabriel qui
est un peu notre conseiller littéraire
quand je dis un peu beaucoup notre
conseiller littéraire et on le remercie
Jean-Félix de la ville beuger
magnifique c'est aux éditions
téémac c'est un livre qui tourne autour
du Rwanda avec un témoignage qui est
celui d'une femme Colette fous
évidemment nous parlons souvent en
matière de littérature de Marguerite
Duras nous l'avons même cité ici le
petit foulard de Marguerite Durance
c'est un témoignage d'amitié de cette
femme donc qui vous savez est une des
grandes dames de la littérature et qui a
fini sa vie à Trouville dans ce fameux
bâtiment des R noir face à la mer et
puis enfin donc pour ceux qui aiment la
montagne s'il reste de la neige et
j'espère qu'il va rester de la neige
voici
donc ce ce livre publié aux éditions
d'argot qui s'appelle donc mur le génie
des alpages donc c'est c'est absolument
magnifique c'est l'intégral c'est une
préface de Jean-Philippe Mercier et euh
le voici
euh ce ce cette bande dessinée merci à
tous les deux la dernière question elle
est tr simple pour il faut conclure et
conclure très vite le meilleur polarard
que vous ayez jamais lu euh c'est un
auteur qui s'appelle Stevens dire deux
choses on a droit deux vous avez le
droit donc l'œuvre de simnon ou et
notamment les pas forcément avec maigré
toute l'escalier de fer le le chat et
cetera pour sé exceptionnel et dans les
polards plus récents il y a un livre que
je conseille mais à tout le monde qui
s'appelle au-delà du mal d'un auteur qui
est paru aussi chez sol latin auteur qui
s'appelle Stevens qui est dans le dans
l'univers des serérial killer ce qui se
fait de mieux on tra pas mieux Hervé
écoutez moi j'ai des goûts assez
classiques
donc moi j'aime Sherlock Holmes donc
toute l'œuvre de Conan Doyle qui pour
moi est vraiment un grand écrivain euh
et qui a qui a l'art de de de poser des
énigmes et de les résoudre donc donc je
je mets tous les Sherlock Holmes et puis
je ne sais pas si vous rangez ça dans
les poares mais moi je suis un un
fanatique du du parrain donc Mario pzzo
euh pour moi c'est un livre de référence
il y a pas d'énigme criminel mais il y a
un récit criminel et euh et le film que
l'on sait et et et tout ce qu'on et tout
ce qu'on lui doit Mario pzzo pour moi
c'est c'est dans le Panthéon et
d'ailleurs retouverez et ce sera le mot
de la fin vous retrouverez cette
ambiance évidemment autour de l'affaire
Markovic la fascination peut-être de
Deon et d'une partie du cinéma pour les
truants sur le Parin vous savez que les
truants étaient extrêmement proches du
tournage de copola avec des pressions
considérables et dans l'entourage de
Delon qui a passé son enfance dans la
cour de freine il a toujours eu
ilailleurs toujours reconnu une sorte de
fascination pour les gens du milieu même
même si le mystère reste entier c'est
justement le charme du bonheur des
livres merci Hervé d'être venu merci
Jacques on était ravi de converser avec
vous et on se retrouve bientôt sur
public scena
[Musique]
Bou